To wrap up this lesson, I really want
you to think about what you've learned
and what you might do next.
Metrics from user behavior and
feedback from users are critical
if you want to improve the product and
forge ahead.
As you reflect on data, you may want
to plan additional design sprints.
We actually did this at Udacity
to rethink student support.
A design sprint can be a great way
to make changes to the product.
You might also discover that
you've chosen a poor metric, or
that you're not retaining users.
If so, then you might want to
rethink your key metrics or
alter the original idea.
Ultimately, it's up to you to iterate on
a product, or reimagine a product, so
that way,
you build something users love.